Can Texas Secede from the Union?
America's second most populated and second
largest state is always first to remind you
that it was once an independent nation: The
Republic of Texas.
Unlike California's three-week, almost accidental
flirt with independence (and a hideous flag)
the Republic of Texas was a real country with
its own presidents, and laws and currency
for a decade from 1836 until 1846 when it
joined the Union to become the 28th state,
thankfully evening out the number of stars.
This happy marriage led pretty much immediately
to the Mexican-American war over the question
of over how big Texas was.
America, as the victor, got to decide the
answer: very big.
While Texas gave up its complete independence
to join The Union, it didn't give up its independent
streak -- and filed for divorce, along with
several other states, a scant 15 years later.
This domestic dispute was settled not with
flowers but with force, something that many
are still grumbly about today.
But History aside in modern times could Texas
still be a real country?
In other words: could Texas succeed if it
secedes?
In terms of population, an independent Texas
would be the world's 46th largest country
with 26 million citizens.
And, those citizens would make Texas the 13th
largest economy.
So the New Texas Republic would be comparable
to Australia, except in the size department.
But what about the Federal money that goes
to Texas?
Those interstate highways don't build themselves,
you know.
For a majority of states, independence would
be a financial problem.
Mississippi, for example get two dollars from
Washington for every one it sends in taxes
so an independent Magnolia Republic would
be bankrupt almost instantly.
But not Texas, which gives more money to the
federal government in taxes than it gets back.
There's no reason why independent Texas couldn't
keep those highways paved *and* give its citizens
a small happy-Texapendency-day Tax cut.
So from a financial perspective: The New Texas
Republic gets a check.
Now the question is can Texas legally secede?
And the answer is... no... not at all.
Despite popular belief, even by politicians
who should know better, the Texas constitution
does not include a get-out-of-The-Union-free
clause no matter how much Texans, or citizens
of other states, wish that it did.
However, the Texas Constitution does have
a weird clause that allows it to divide itself
into five states without the approval of congress.
So Texas could, any moment, explode into the
states perhaps named North Texas, South Texas,
East Texas, West Texas and Austin -- which
would quintuple its power in the Senate -- but
not necessarily help it gain independence
because there is no legal process for a state
to exit The Union.
Though the constitution is mute on the issue,
secession has come before the supreme court
and, shockingly, the Supreme Court of the
United States decided that States can't leave
the United States.
But the legal question is, weirdly sort of
moot.
After all, the First Texas Republic didn't
pop into existence out of nowhere -- Texas
was originally a State of Mexico, which didn't
allow Texas to leave, but leave Texas did
anyway, though under less than harmonious
circumstances.
While it's hard to imagine war between the
New Texas Republic and the United States it
isn't hard to imagine who would win that fight.
Texas does have its own military, but seriously,
nobody beats America in the war business.
So the only way Texas is leaving is if it
can convince the United States to change its
laws to let it leave.
Which only as a chance of being discussed
seriously if a majority of Texans want independence,
which isn't remotely the case.
So while a New Texas Republic is interesting
to think about -- particularly for some non-Texans,
as of now it's a long way from becoming a
reality.